hallo leute ich es wieder einmal
willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich habe mich lange nicht gemeldet seit
2000 17
und es ist noch nicht so lange her ich
habe über weihnachten so ein bisschen
frei gemacht und jetzt noch im januar
weil ich ja umgezogen werden und so ganz
viele sachen das erledigen musste und
deswegen gab es kein neues video
so sieht aus und jetzt komme ich aber
zurück mit raclette essen und ihr denkt
so wenn der islam aber ist das nicht
noch schon lang vorbei ist es eigentlich
schon aber ich habe noch so viele und so
viel regnet käse dass ich dachte
wieso nicht das ist voll die gute idee
entschuldigt meine haare ich habe
geduscht weil ich für euch fresh & clean
sein wollte und ich will noch tageslicht
haben und deswegen habe ich hier
angefangen zu drehen
ich möchte jetzt zum anfang eine kritik
die ich meine raclette essen
ich will jetzt nicht in den kommentaren
wissen wann es aber raclette ist man so
haben wir ein netter mann ist rugby ich
weiß man ist drei kletterer so wie man
es möchte und ich möchte käse das ist
vollkommen mit ich hab noch nie alleine
raclette gegessen aber beinhart ich
mache mal gleich ein paar mehr fertig
und dann wenn man allein ist dann kann
man sich eure die können okay was soll
der geiz und jetzt warten wir
ich überlege gerade vorüber ich hatte
eigentlich sprechen wollte und ich
glaube das mache ich jetzt spontan denn
so schnell auf die schnelle ist mir dann
doch nicht so viele parteien gefallen
doch die möchte sprechen über jetzt
fällt mir das nicht mehr einig hatte das
im kopf wie schmeckt videos darüber
gespräche nie vermisst ich auch ich weiß
auch nicht warum ich es ist noch nicht
hingekriegt haben immer dritten mit
meinem hund los wenn ich brauche ich das
nicht hinkriegt habe jetzt irgendwie und
wie schmeckt zu drehen ich habe viele
viele sachen nicht reden möchte also
meine liste ist wirklich so lang aber
irgendwie weil sie nicht stimmt ich habe
eine neue küche durch die neue wohnung
macht wenn und hier habe ich schon auch
bibi und tina gedreht also der
butterkuchen von frau martina und mir
hat das mit der kameraeinstellung schon
gefallen ich dann dabei irgendwie hat es
noch nicht so ganz
ihr müsst es mal sagen jetzt wenn ihr
das bibi und tina wieder video
vergleicht mit einem alten geschmeckt
ausnahmen aus meiner alten küche sagt
mal was euch besser gefällt oder ob ich
vielleicht das nicht so ja wie ihr das
einfach findet wenn mir noch nicht ganz
das finde und ich muss auch gucken weil
ich müsste jetzt eigentlich ein anderes
objektiv kaufen aber das ist so viel
technischer kram den ich noch nicht
richtig verstehe aber das werden wir
doch alles hinkriegen
also seid ihr aber was ganz dringendes
haben wollt was ich mir nicht schmeckt
kochen soll dann schreibt einfach in die
kommentare und dann sehe ich das auch
ist es gut mein gott ist das ding war
habt ihr eigentlich kalt gegessen also
da wo ihr wart an silvester weihnachten
kennt ihr das ich habe erst mal erklärt
das erste mal mit 20 oder so also sauer
später nahmen das nie gemacht deswegen
kann ich das auch überhaupt nicht daher
nicht schon genug aktive gibt gibt es
jetzt hier noch grillkäse wo ich möchte
aber auch gerne rum diary auf jeden fall
jetzt ab januar wieder starten ich
vermisse dieses format selber schon ich
habe gemerkt dass ich irgendwie
vielleicht auch wegen den grundzug und
so aber ich hatte das gefühl dass ich in
den letzten wochen sind bisschen
schwammig war was meine videos angehen
weil ich habe ja selbst die formate die
ich auch selber alle mark und ich könnte
dir einfach machen besonders die formate
wie ihr euch auch so gefallen ich weiß
aber nicht was was das problem ist also
warum warum es mich warum ich mich da
beschwert also ich bin maler klett käse
macht den kurz warm und dann packe ich
da noch meisten drauf weil ich liebe
käse und mais und einfach ist wieder
rein
so einfach ist das super tolles rezept
hier machen wir das auch meist vorne
heiße kartoffel armee gott ist die heißt
wie magisch ist allein das geld zu essen
stehlen wie deine oma als ihr
beigebracht hat auch wie man ein neuer
weihnachtsfest wie waren eure
weihnachtstage hatte die urlaub konntet
ihr ein bisschen entspannen
also ich dass mein weihnachten war
wunderschön
also ich habe auch schon serien
weihnachten sehr mir weihnachten gefällt
habe habe ich gesagt dass unsere
weihnachten wie aus dem die care katalog
war alles war so harmonisch und das war
haben getanzt getrunken und später sind
wir dann noch eine bar mit freunden und
es war irgendwie einfach perfekt so das
kommt jetzt oben drauf teils okay diese
kartoffeln und mais
oh mein gott gebe es nicht
schon das dritte mal dass ich seit
silvester hat es so viel respekt wieso
gekauft haben völlig unterschätzt aber
danach es jetzt auch mal gut ich kann
aber auch was ganz blödes erzählen
das kam heute mein neuer schnitt pc
jahren weil ich endlich mal einen guten
pc zu schneiden ist hier aber der pcr
gebacken und das war dann jetzt kann ich
nicht benutzen könnte ich ihn wieder
zurück geschickt
das online bestellen eigentlich bestell
ich richtig also ich bestelle ich kenne
jeder wünscht sich in sachen aber
eigentlich mag ich online-bestellungen
weil das einfach und schnell geht aber
wenn irgendwas nicht passten sie ist es
nicht so an da muss alles wieder
einpacken
besonders kompliziert muss alles wieder
einpacken und dann bei mir auch schon
meistens nicht wohin damit weil ich kann
einem pc liegt irgendwo hin tragen ich
habe kein auto habe ich das jetzt den
postboten mit als nächste mal kommt oder
muss ja nicht aus damit der kommen und
das machen auch nicht alle recht glaube
das macht nur der mensch ich sag euch
kapiert ist das beste land der welt so
ist einfach sachen und zog sie nur ein
pc sein
sarah green ich sage was zurück wie ich
weiß nicht warum ich so kriegen sage
habe man gedacht dass es richtig und
irgendwann hat mich letztes jemand
darauf hingewiesen dass sie nicht so
ganz richtig ist wir können ja mal was
jahr 2000 abzusprechen habt ihr eure
vorsätze schon gebrochen oder geschafft
oder oder wie sie an sagt dieses jahr
bei euch mit den vorsätzen aus
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine gemacht
hatte vettel ist damit dinge die ich
endlich mal ledigen muss und ich habe
sie mir an die wand gehängt
30 prozent haben schon erledigt das ding
ist
ich wohne ja das erste mal wirklich
alleine und bin nicht in eine wg
eingezogen
weil sonst ich bin ja er habe jetzt in
berlin habe ich jetzt schon in fünf
wohnung gewohnt
ja aber da war halt immer alles schon
angemeldet habt dann immer dem
hauptmieter oder einfach jemandem der
überwiesen
dass ich dann halt das internet und so
ist ein strom bezahlen
aber dieses mal musste ich eine
internet- und strom auch anmelden und
ich habe das noch nie gemacht ich hab
mich noch nie damit befasst für mich war
das wirklich eine krise ein rätsel was
heißt überhaupt heiß was man da machen
muss glaube ich habs jetzt aber
geschafft also mit dem strom bin ich
noch nicht so ganz durch versteht
überhaupt nicht youtube keine ahnung von
nix
also 2018 einmal meine haare sind nicht
allzu schlimm aus oder steht
ich hatte sie mir auch abgeschnitten
aber nicht also wenn jemand hat das
geschrieben weil ich hatte mir nie
abgeschnitten und her überlegt soll ich
darüber video irgendwas sagen oder so da
habe ich habe ich in einem video kurz
gesagt ja ich habe jetzt gehandelt weil
ich das auch so komisch an ist darüber
ein video zu machen dass ich mir die
haare abgeschnitten habe aber die besten
beat also die videos wo man die haare
abschneidet oder die frisur verändert
die laufen so gut ich gehöre auch dazu
wenn die mal wieder im video we are
macht man das sofort an
ich hab ich ja da können die leute jetzt
gut sage und zwar eine spontane
entscheidung
nein ich hatte gerade keine trennung in
meinem leben alles in ordnung mich an
meinen die haare gehabt und ich finde es
gibt viel zu wenig frauen mit kurzen und
frauen mit kurzen hand da steht die
meisten eigentlich mal besser ich bin
sogar mir steht das besser dass sich
kürzere haare ab anstatt das irgendwie
hier bis unten hängt ich hatte ja
letztes jahr im sommer sind dieses jahr
so machen ich letztes jahr doch letztes
jahr um ein ganz weiter gemacht sind
letztes jahr im sommer hatte ich letztes
jahr um dramatische ganz extensions drin
von nike und das war schon ganz cool so
lange haare zu haben aber ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen wie dass frauen sich
immer wieder rein machen also
anstrengend ist das sind nämlich so
tables hat gerade so ein video gemacht
hat sind die ausprobiert und das sind so
eine take lebst du dir halt dran ans
haar und das klingt schon liiert und das
fühlt sich auch wird an also es ist kann
ich mir durch den kopf fassen und das
war so komisch dieses gefühl dass ich
das dann nicht mehr weitermachen wollte
ich nicht für mich und ich habe mir
lange meine fingernägel nicht gemacht
denn ich hab nicht mehr eingesehen
fehler gemacht
kosten 35 euro in berlin in anderen
städten ist ja sogar noch teurer
also ich weiß dass in stuttgart glaube
ich 50 euro oder so und berlin 35 euro
und ich habe nicht mal ein gesehen für
meine nägel 65 voraus wie man sieht
super schöner wenn sie gemacht sind und
so frisch lackiert und so ein bisschen
verlängert und startet dann sind sie
auch härter aber nicht für 35 euro und
jetzt habe ich das beste gemacht
ich habe mir ein professionelles gehen
nagel set gekauft für ich glaube 100
euro also ich werde es auch im video mit
euch ausprobieren
ich bin sehr gespannt ob man das selber
machen kann ich hatte jetzt schon so
fünf sechs mal mehr die nägel machen
lassen also ich hab so ein gefühl dafür
wie man es machen muss aber man kommt
natürlich nicht von professionellen
nageldesign haben dran seid ihr bereit
für käse porn wollen wir vielleicht noch
mal über 2.800 sprechen 2018
was passiert 2018 nun ja meine kinder
2018 wird sehr spannend für mich und
natürlich auch für euch dieses jahr ist
mein größtes ziel ein wie schmeckt's
kochbuch zu bringen ich weiß nicht ob
ich das schaffe doch eigentlich will ich
schaffen
ich habe jetzt so eine des jahres müsste
es rauskommt das heißt ich habe noch ein
paar monate zeit das wird auch sehr viel
eher sehr sehr sehr viel zeit in
anspruch nehmen dieses kochbuch zu
machen weil ich eine große frage habt
wie meint dass mit den rechten das ding
ist nämlich es gibt ja auch zum beispiel
das inoffizielle kochbuch von harry
potter und da weiß jetzt nicht ob sie
die autorin mit dem gehört wie die
westlb oder die kollegen gleich fünf
minuten gerade mich ja auf jeden fall
hat sie ja nicht die rechte oder hat sie
die chance bekommen oder heißt das buch
das inoffizielle kochbuch weil sie die
rechte nicht hat dieses video ist auch
nicht zu lang machen sehe mich ja
wahrscheinlich erstmal
in kleinen portionen wieder genießen bis
wie schmeckt es kommt buch und ich
möchte unbedingt jetzt mal ins ausland
reisen also eine reise machen
ich weiß aber überhaupt nicht wohin
schottland ist zum beispiel land was ich
sehr gerne sehen wollen würde aber das
ist auch nicht so weit weg
dann würde ich schon lieber etwas noch
weiter weg fahren kanada kanada finnland
das würde ich gerne mal sehen
hallo da gibt es ganz schön sie zu sehen
ich glaube das ist so ein landes könnte
mir richtig gut gefallen dass lasst uns
doch alle mal auf den gemeinsam ins neue
jahr starten fragt mir meine kommentare
was sie einfach auch gerne von mir sehen
wollen wird oder was sind eure lieblings
formate was was schaut euch am liebsten
dass ich das auch mal einschätzen kann
oh mein gott er im dezember day blogs
machen wollen unterschiedlichen video
das hat überhaupt nicht funktioniert
nach dem fünften tag war ich so kaputt
da muss jemand wirklich lachen wenn ich
in kommentaren lese oder irgendwelche
nachrichten kriege herr bald was ist
daran so schlimm sind aber andere leute
arbeiten ja auch acht stunden tag
deswegen ist das ist darum gar nicht
geht es wenig um die arbeitszeit die du
auch rein steckt natürlich das ist auch
ein großer punkt warum die videos machen
oder viele videos machen hält
anstrengend sein kann weil man einfach
viel zeit investiert aber man muss sich
halt auch vorstellen vor einer kamera zu
sitzen
ich finde das ist ich könnte zum
beispiel acht stunden am tag einen text
schreiben oder bei lebe regal einpacken
das geht acht stunden
das ist okay so man fängt an und
nachstunden hört man auf pause
dazwischen das habe ich genauso schon
mal gemacht oder öfter ich finde aber du
kannst nicht acht stunden lang vor einer
kamera sitzen und reden gut kann die
allgemeine entsprechen schnitts player
sind da ja irgendwie ein bisschen anders
die setzten sich am morgens vom pc bis
acht bis abends in die kamera haben
videos für drei monate
wenn jetzt noch dran seid schaut mal bei
dem neuen format vorbei was ich mit
jonas und lisa mache das ist ein format
das heißt plan und los wir machen da
echt geile videos also das thema dieses
formats ist halt dass wir fragen
beantworten wie man so hart wenn man ein
junger mensch ist und jetzt nicht wie
werden kinder gemacht sondern was mache
ich nach der schule was ist besser eine
eigene wohnung oder eine wg also dem
land hatten solche fragen mit
spezialisten auf also wir denn sonst das
nicht alles einfach aus ist alles gut
recherchiert und ich mag dieses format
sehr gerne oder diesen kanal also
schaute ich werde noch jahre weiterer
glad essen weil ich es nicht schaffe
diesen käse auf zu
essen ich schaffe aber auch nicht mehr
als sechs scheiben danach bin ich voll
voller käse und ab montag geht es aber
wieder richtig regulär los dann fangen
wir am montag zu drehen und seinen video
also da will ich wieder in den workflow
reinkommen das ist alles wieder
regelmäßig kommt dann ist auch so quasi
mein urlaub vorbei ist jetzt auch
irgendwie schon vorbei war noch nicht
ganz seinen mut gemacht wissen ganz
entspannt ist ein video ich habe jetzt
gegessen mit euch also das ist jetzt
nicht so viel arbeit ja ansonsten
wünsche ich euch einen wunderschönen tag
wir sehen uns dann bei dem nächsten
video wieder was wahrscheinlich wie
schmeckt sein wird weil sehen wir mal
ehrlich leute das ist das einzige was
ihr mittlerweile nur noch von mir wollt
wie schmeckt das auch in ordnung
es macht mir sehr viel spaß gut dann
seid ihr noch weitere videos und hier
könnt ihr mich abonnieren und dann bis
zum ist heute noch ein bisschen ich habe
hier noch käse meist meisten krise